tonight cyber safe pairing geared
towards protecting the entire family as
the russian invasion continues in
ukraine there's a heightened risk the
war could move from the air and ground
into the cyber realm and there are ways
to protect your family from a war that
would know no
borders the war in ukraine could move
beyond borders with a digital battle
it's been publicly disseminated that
prior to
putin sending forces into ukraine they
launched a massive cyber attack
targeting their their critical
infrastructure such as their energy
their media you know their ability to
communicate with heavy sanctions levied
against russia we spoke to our cyber
expert lieutenant larson about the risk
of a russian cyber attack against
america i don't think that you know we
need to be at a level of panic where
people are rushing to the bank to pull
out funds but i do think there's an
elevated risk right now for a cyber
attack in the case a bank you use was
knocked off the grid for hours even days
may be a time to keep more cash and
supplies on hand having some cash on
hand some you know additional food water
things like that in your house is always
a good idea
regardless of what's going on but i
would say that you know you do still
have insurance with the banking
institutions for those in the markets
having some of your portfolio accessible
that you have a year's worth of spending
and you don't have to worry about those
ups and downs in the market day-to-day
and with so many wanting to help
ukrainians look into the legitimacy of
who you're giving to we've seen
additional scams popping up of you know
give money to ukraine with russian
hackers possibly coming at american
businesses this is a time to shore up
company-wide cyber security really
having good what we call cyber hygiene
that's not reusing passwords using
authenticator applications and
encryption technology updating software
and restricting admin privileges when
you have
you know different countries throughout
western europe and the united states and
other north american countries for that
matter all sanctioning some of these
russian banks and these russian accounts
biggest thing is that there's definitely
an elevated risk of foreign actors